♪ ♪
>> MEXICO HAS GOT TO HELP US AT
THE BORDER.
IF THEY ARE NOT GOING TO HELP US
AT THE BORDER, IT'S A VERY SAD
THING BETWEEN TWO COUNTRIES.
MEXICO HAS GOT TO HELP US AT THE
BORDER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE COMING IN
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE DACA.
BUT MEXICO HAS GOT TO HELP US AT
THE BORDER.
THEY BLOW RIGHT THROUGH MEXICO,
IT CAN HAPPEN THAT WAY ANYMORE.
>> Katie: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY,"
AMERICA'S ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
PRICES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CALLING UP
MEXICO AND PUSHING HIS
GOVERNMENT TO DO ITS PART AND
HELP SECURE THE BORDER BETWEEN
OUR TWO COUNTRIES.
THIS COMES AS MIGRANTS FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA ARE FLOWING
THROUGH MEXICO INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
THE SITUATION ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, JUST HOW BAD IS IT?
JOINING US NOW IS 20 YEAR BORDER
PATROL VETERAN BRANDON JUDD AND
FORMER ARIZONA SHERIFF.
BRANDON, YOUR REACTION ON THE
PRESIDENT CALLING ON MEXICO TO
DO MORE?
>> HE DID THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT
THING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, MEXICO IS
FACILITATING -- THE GOVERNMENT
OF MEXICO IS ACTUALLY
FACILITATING THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO COME UP TO OUR BORDERS AND
BREAK U.S. LAW OR THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE SHOULD ABSOLUTELY CALL ON THE
LEADERS OF THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT TO PUT AN END TO
THIS.
THEY HAVE VERY STRICT
IMMIGRATION LAWS, YET THEY ARE
THROWING THEIR LAWS OVER THEIR
SHOULDER TO ALLOW THESE PEOPLE
TO COME UP AND BREAK OUR LAWS.
THAT CANNOT HAPPEN.
>> Katie: SHERIFF, I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE OF THIS.
YOU WERE IN CHARGE OF A COUNTY,
NOT A PORTER COUNTY, BUT IN A
BORDER STATE, HAS BORDER COUNTYP
BORDER STATE, HAS BORDER COUNTYO
BORDER STATE, HAS BORDER COUNTYL
BORDER STATE, HAS BORDER COUNTYM
BORDER STATE, HAS BORDER COUNTY.
TALK ABOUT HOW WOULD MEXICO
ALLOWS THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO
COME THROUGH INTO THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT STOPPING
THEM ARE
BETTING THEM, HOW THAT AFFECTS
DEPUTIES ON THE GROUND.
>> WELCOME A CRIME.
ONE, YOU ARE ADDING CRIMINAL
ILLEGALS BESIDES IT'S NOT JUST
OF MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
ILLEGALS WHO ARE HERE, MANY OF
THEM, AS PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
POINTED OUT, HAVE CRIMINAL
RECORDS IN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
FIGURES AS HIGH AS 30% OF THESE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS.
THERE IS A COST OF THAT, NOT
JUST IN TERMS OF INCARCERATION
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT ALSO
WITH EDUCATION, AND MEDICAL
CARE, IT'S ESTIMATED JUST FOR
THE STATE OF ARIZONA, YOUR HOME
STATE, WHICH WE ARE VERY PROUD
OF YOU, CLOSE TO $2 BILLION
EVERY YEAR.
SO THIS IS AN EXTREME COST, NOT
JUST IN TERMS OF THE SOCIAL AND
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ASPECT BUT
IN TERMS OF ACTUAL DOLLARS AND
CENTS.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT HERE IS THAT
THESE ARE NOT JUST ILLEGALS
BEING ESCORTED BY COYOTES OR
GUIDES, THIS IS AN ACTUAL,
ALMOST AS BRANDON POINTED OUT,
SANCTIONED BY THE GOVERNMENT OF
MEXICO, 1200 POTENTIALLY
MARCHING TOWARDS THE BORDER.
EVEN THOUGH THAT MAY SOUND LIKE
A SMALL NUMBER, HOW WE DEAL WITH
THIS SENT A MESSAGE TO MEXICO,
TO CENTRAL AMERICA, BECAUSE IF
WE ACCEPT THEM AS REFUGEES OR
ASYLUM-SEEKERS, WE ARE GOING TO
SEE TENS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
REPLICATING THIS.
>> Katie: PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
A LITTLE BIT OF HEAT TODAY FOR
SAYING AND ARGUING THAT THESE
ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF DACA.
WHAT HE SHOULD HAVE SAID AS THEY
ARE COMING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ANY KIND OF AMNESTY THAT GETS
PUT ON THE TABLE FOR PEOPLE WHO
GET ON THEIR GROUND HERE.
WE SALVE US IN 2014 WITH THE
CHILD IMMIGRATION, UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR CRISIS, WHEN PEOPLE
JUST SEND THEIR KIDS UP BUT KNEW
THAT IF THEY COULD GO THERE AND
STAY THERE, THEY WOULD GET SENT
TO A FAMILY MEMBER IN THE
UNITED STATES AND NEVER BE SENT
BACK.
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT WHEN
ANYONE IN WASHINGTON STARTS
TALKING ABOUT AMNESTY, DACA COME
THE TREATMENT PROGRAM, ANYTHING,
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEO
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEF
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEU
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEA
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEC
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEM
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEA
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASEI
CITIZENSHIP, WE SEE AN INCREASED
MINORS, ILLEGAL ALIENS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER, SPECIFICALLY
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS,
FAMILY UNITS MAKING IT ACROSS
HOPING TO GET TO STAY.
>> ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS GO DOWN
AND SPEAK WITH THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE IMPACTED.
THE RANCHERS.
I WAS OUT ON A TOUR OF THE
BORDER WITH SENATOR CORNYN,
SENATOR HELLER, AND A COUPLE OF
OTHER SENATORS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO.
AND WE WERE AT A RANCH ESTATE.
THE OWNERS OF THE ESTATE
SPECIFICALLY SAID EVERY SINGLE
TIME WE START TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION REFORM OR AN
AMNESTY, WE SEE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE COME ACROSS OUR RANCH.
THEY FIND DEAD BODIES ON THE
RANCH ALL THE TIME.
AND THE INCREASE IS ALWAYS WHEN
WE START TALKING ABOUT AN
AMNESTY PROGRAM.
WE CANNOT TALK ABOUT ANY SORT OF
AMNESTY, WHETHER THAT'S DACA OR
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM, UNLESS WE SECURE THE
BORDER FIRST.
ONCE WE SECURE THE BORDER, THEN
WE CAN START TALKING ABOUT
THINGS SO THAT WE DON'T PUT
OURSELVES IN THIS SAME SITUATION
FIVE, TEN YEARS FROM NOW.
THE BILL IN 1986 WAS SUPPOSED TO
FIX THAT PROBLEM.
IT DIDN'T.
THEY PUT THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE.
THEY LEGALIZED EVERYBODY BUT
THEY DIDN'T PUT THE BORDER
SECURITY MEASURES IN PLACE.
WE HAVE TO PUT THE BORDER
SECURITY MEASURES IN PLACE
FIRST.
>> Katie: THE WHITE HOUSE MADE
IT VERY CLEAR THEY WANT TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM ONCE AND FOR ALL.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE DEALING
WITH LATER ON.
SHERIFF, I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE HUMAN ASPECT OF THIS.
PEOPLE WHO STAND UP FOR BORDER
SECURITY ARE ACCUSED OF BEING
INHUMANE, RACIST, THEY ARE
ACCUSED OF NOT BEING EMPATHETIC
TO THOSE WHO ARE FLEEING VIOLENT
SITUATIONS.
WHAT ABOUT THE JOURNEY HERE?
I'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT OPEN
BORDERS ARE INHUMANE BORDERS.
I'M SURE THAT YOU'VE SEEN SOME
TERRIBLE THINGS AS A RESULT OF
PEOPLE BEING TOLD BY THESE
COYOTES, WE'LL TAKE CARE OF YOU,
WE'LL TAKE YOU THROUGH THE
DESERT, MAKE SURE IT HAPPENS
JUST FINE, AND IT ACTUALLY TURNS
OUT TO BE A HORRIFIC EXPERIENCE
FOR THESE PEOPLE.
>> IT IS.
THEY ARE VICTIMIZED.
NOT ONLY IT'S BRUTAL BECAUSE OF
THE BARREN DESERTS AND THEY
THEM DIE, HUNDREDS EACH YEAR,
IT'S ESTIMATED, AND THEY ARE
VICTIMIZED AS WELL.
NOT ONLY THEY ARE SPENDING THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS, GIVING IT TO THESE
ESCORTS, THESE COYOTES, THEY ARE
ROBBING THEM.
THEY ARE RAPING THEM.
WE'VE HAD COUNTLESS CASES IN MY
EIGHT YEARS OF SHERIFF'S WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN RAPED MULTIPLE
TIMES AS JUVENILES.
TO YOUR POINT, WHERE LIBERAL SAY
WE ARE NOT COMPASSIONATE OR TRUE
TO OUR PROUD OF HIM HISTORY AS A
LEAD OF IMMIGRANTS, COMPLETELY
FALSE.
WE ARE THE MOST COMPASSIONATE,
MOST GENEROUS NATION TO THIS
DAY, NEARLY 1 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS EACH AND EVERY YEAR
THAT WE ALLOW IN.
FAR AN EXCESS OF NATION.
WE ARE PROUD OF THAT.
WE CAN'T JUST HAVE OPEN BORDERS
AND WHOEVER WANTS TO GET TO THE
BORDER, YOU ARE HOME FREE.
THOSE WHERE THE OBAMA DAYS AND
WE ARE DONE WITH IT WAS.